مشاهدينا دعونا نعود اليوم الى عام 1963
تحديدا مع اغتيال الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
جي اف كندي بطلقه ناريه في وضح النهار
طبعا في مدينه دالاس منذ ذلك الحين بقيت
جريمه اغتيال الرئيس الامريكي لغز لم تكشف
ابعاده حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا مع اقتراب
موعد الانتخابات الامريكيه عادت القضيه
غير المكتمله الى الظهور فلربما يكون لدى
ترامب هذه المره الاجابات للتفاصيل
الناقصه في مقابله خاصه مع صحيفه ماسنجر
صرح الرئيس الامريكي السابق بانه سيكشف عن
جميع الوثائق السريه المتعلقه بقضيه كندي
الوثائق كان قد تم حجبها عمدا عن الشعب
الامريكي من اجل حمايه الامن القومي
وانفاذ القانون طبعا بحسب خبراء لكن وعد
ترامب هذا طبعا جاء بشرط هذا الوعد بان
يعد انتخابه للرئاسه الامريكيه مجددا
روبرت كندي نجل شقيق جون
ومرشح اخر في سباق الانتخابات الامريكيه
ادلى الشهر الماضي بالتصريحات صادمه اتهم
فيها المخابرات الامريكيه باغتيال عمه
تصريحات تعد تحديا واضحا للروايه الرسميه
للحكومه الامريكيه عن مطلق النار الوحيد
لهارفي اوزولد والذي يزعم انه كان عميلا
للاتحاد السوفيتي في عام 1992 كان الرئيس
انداك جورج بوش الاب والذي كان يشغل منصب
مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه وقد وقع
قانونا يفرض الكشف العالمي عن جميع
الوثائق المتعلقه بجون كندي مع ذلك امتنعت
الادارات المتعاقبه بما في ذلك اداره
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن عن الكشف عن مضمون
هذه الوثائق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات